So hello and welcome and a special welcome to our guest today,
Helen Scales and Aaron John Gregory.
Helen Scales is a British marine biologist,
a broadcaster and writer professor scale swam all the way over here from
Cambridge University where she teaches marine biology in science writing serves
as a scientific advisor to the marine conservation charity.
See Changers.
You may know her from her BBC radio programs such as inside science,
shared planet outlook and weekend.
Her previous books include spirals in time,
the secret life and curious afterlife of seashells and Poseidon Steed,
the story of sea horses from myth to reality.
Her new book
I have the shoal is an attempt to unhitch fish from their reputation as slimy
simple minded creatures and reveal their mesmerizing and complex lives.
The illustrator of the book is Aaron John Gregory.
In addition to this book,
Aron's illustration work includes God,
Zillow range across time or IDW comics,
furry logic,
the physics of animal life and the book for the Smithsonian called Narwhal
revealing and Arctic legend which accompanied the reason exhibit in DC and Erin
also with the illustrator for one of Alan's previous books.
So trying to liberty you.
Thank you.
That
very much.
Thank you so much for that lovely introduction.
And thank you all for coming along this afternoon.
Of anyone who's listening,
uh,
online.
Um,
my name is Hernan Scales and yeah,
I'm a marine biologist.
Uh,
and just,
just to clear things up right from the start,
I often do get asked about my name,
uh,
and just,
just make sure it is my real name.
Um,
but I'm not the only marine biologists with a cool name.
I have a couple of other favorites.
There's teddy girl.
He was at an American at theologist,
uh,
about a hundred years ago.
Um,
this guy's still around.
Stephen Paddock actually is nearby where we are now in Monterey Bay Aquarium
Research Institute.
He studies jellyfish as you can see on his t shirt.
And this is,
uh,
one of my absolute favorite and marine biologists,
marine fish.
And we're going to come back to her later.
Um,
it's a real pleasure to be here today.
especially because,
um,
this is the first opportunity I've had to appear alongside,
Aaron,
John Gregory,
who was become a dear friend.
But basically we've been working together for a couple of years now.
I'm on my books.
Um,
he's been bringing to life these wonderful creatures that I write about.
So today's the first opportunity we've had to actually appear together and to
talk about our different sides of the,
of,
of this,
um,
collaboration.
Um,
so what we're gonna do is I'm going to introduce the book,
tell you a little bit about what I've written about,
um,
go into a few of the stories I tell,
and then we're going to hear from a about what he does to produce beautiful
artwork.
I should go back to that first slide actually.
Cause this is an image that sadly we were going to have on the front and the
back cover of the book.
This is the front cover.
This is going to be the back cover,
which is very beautiful hills,
has a t shirt with.
Um,
but my publisher's insisted on putting words on the back of my book instead of
beautiful pictures.
So this is what it should looked like.
Um,
so here we go.
So yeah,
I have the shoal.
Um,
the fish watch this guide to life,
the oceans and everything.
The idea behind the book really is to bring to life this group of animals that I
think kind of get a bit of a raw deal.
They,
um,
they inhabit the oceans,
which is the biggest living space on the planet.
It's something like 90% of the available biosphere,
the living place for creatures to occupy,
90% of the space on our planet is ocean.
And I would argue that the,
oh,
the fish really reign supreme in this enormous round,
certainly amongst the vertebrates.
So,
um,
there are about 30,000 species official life today,
which is the same number as all of the other vertebrates put together.
So 30,000 fish,
but also 30,000 mammals,
amphibians,
birds,
reptiles,
all put together.
So there's an awful lot of fish and they get up to some incredible things down
beneath the waves.
They come in all sorts of shapes and sizes and they do some pretty awesome
stuff.
So just to give you an idea,
some of my favorites,
a little run down of some of my favorite fish.
We have the Greenland shock a recently discovered that this guy lives for 500
years or can do a longest lived vertebra.
It on the planets putting incredible,
they live under the Arctic ice.
Uh,
they hunt polar bears.
Um,
they,
the hearts beat five times a minute.
It's pretty crazy things.
Um,
and they're huge.
They're about I think,
eight meters long.
So pretty huge things.
Here's the words,
world's smallest fish.
Uh,
it doesn't even have a common name.
It's called Peter crypsis pro genetic.
Uh,
this is at full grown.
they live in the peat swamps of Borneo.
So fish can be very small and that can be huge.
And the for ages,
I think these guys probably only live for a couple of weeks.
Um,
and yeah,
and fish do some extraordinary things,
which we're just really beginning to learn about through technologies that are
helping us to see into the depths and to track their,
their lives.
And one example I love to give is the Bluefin tuna.
The here in California has quite a good example to give because it was kind of
local,
at least for part of its life.
So the Bluefin tuna,
this particular species from the North Pacific is born off the coast of Japan
and they feed off the coast of California.
Did they come over here?
And they make this incredible journey.
And we know about this because of the,
we have satellite tracking technology,
which can now be small enough to stick a tag onto a fish and track where it
goes.
And,
and here's just one example of one particular tuner that underwent,
this was born in Japan under one to this migration,
uh,
to California.
If then went back to Japan to spawn itself.
And then the tag kept going and it came all the way back to California.
So over the course of just 20 months,
it's migrated 40,000 kilometers,
which is the equivalent of the entire circumference of the planets,
which is amazing.
So fish aren't just wandering around randomly through the oceans.
They are,
they are undergoing journeys to find places they need to be for different
resources,
um,
and navigating in very smart ways,
which was still only just learning about how they make these great journeys and
know where they're going.
Um,
so we extraordinary things,
but fish don't all swim huge distances.
Um,
some of them tend to stay put.
Now I'm gonna show you a little video clip that I,
um,
I shot a couple of years ago.
Hopefully it's going to work in Fiji.
Let's try again,
just a really simple little underwater camera.
My photography skills.
Great.
I was interested in this fish here,
which is a trigger fish and there was just lots of colorful fish from you around
and I thought,
well this is awesome.
Lovely.
Um,
and it did take me a little while to realize there's another fish in this
picture.
Um,
but she can't have first seen.
It's really not too clear in this picture anyway,
but just to give you a hint,
it's down here.
Um,
and it's a stone fish and again,
you kind of ICAK closer and took some more shots of it.
Um,
it is a bit clearer on the monitor then on the screen,
but just to give you a clue,
there's an eye here and there was a mouse.
These are incredibly well camouflaged fish.
Um,
it's one of those,
I mean I've,
I call the book the fish watchers guide to life,
the oceans and everything.
Cause one thing I want to do is encourage people to go and watch fish and see
them and appreciate them in the wild.
And you get like super high points for spotting one of these guys because
they're so hard to pick out when you do.
You're like,
yeah.
Um,
I've seen that the impossible to see fish.
Ada,
you've,
you've had some up close encounters with these guys.
Yeah.
Um,
so years ago I used to own a tropical fish store,
so Fisher kind of been a part of my life.
Um,
which is interesting that Helen didn't notice it at first,
which is a little dangerous because some of you might know this is actually one
of those lethal venomous fish on the planet.
And if she were to say kind of rest your,
you put your hand down on that rock,
these guys can kill you.
And like five,
10 minutes,
there's no,
there's no like antivenom.
There's no like,
hey,
let's get to the hospital or anything compared to Scorpion fish and lion fish,
which would ruin your day if you had like an allergic reaction to them can
really ruin your day.
These guys would would take you out.
And so when I want a tropical fish door,
surprising you could buy these,
it doesn't pet.
And so I had one on the front counter of the store and the tank about Yay big,
a cylinder kind of hexagon,
just enough space for a couple of inches of gravel around him and he would just
bury himself in the gravel.
And so customers would come up and he'd see this empty tube and you know what's
in that tank?
When I owned the tropical fish store,
I was pretty young.
Disclaimer,
will the 23 so I thought stuff like this was super cool,
I want to get well and I grab a feeder goldfish and I throw it in the tube and
the gravel would just erupt and these things would attack and hit their food in
a of like milliseconds.
It's gun gunshot quick and you know,
goldfish or disappear.
There'd be some scales,
you know,
floating about and then people will be blown away.
And then I go ahead and tell him like,
and by the way,
if you were to put your hand,
in fact they would kill you.
It was just always,
you know,
blow people's minds.
But yeah,
he's,
he's a pretty,
pretty cool fish.
Yeah.
There's this really cool that you say that they hide and then basically want to
just grab the food that comes close to them,
whether it's a gold fish in a tank or one of those fish swimming around.
Um,
so a completely different strategy to those tuna,
which are swimming miles and miles and miles to find that food.
These guys just sit and wait.
Um,
so I guess my point is that fish just have very different strategies to survive
and thrive and the oceans to find their food and,
and get the stuff they need.
Um,
and they did some pretty pretty wacky stuff.
So,
wait.
So the one,
a couple of things that I'm trying to do in the book,
um,
his boss,
some of the,
the really ingrained myths that we have about fish,
which I do think puts a barrier between us and them in times of understanding
them as wildlife.
I want people to appreciate these things as,
as beautiful,
fascinating creatures and not just as food or as dcs,
slimy,
smelly,
boring things.
And I think this is one reason why we do kind of have this distance with fish
compared to other vertebrates with birds and mammals is this idea that they have
really terrible memories.
Like the three second memory thing,
I don't know if you've come across this and when Ms. Seven seconds for Goldfish,
like,
you know,
swimming around his bowl and oh,
it's okay.
I don't remember what happened last time round.
Um,
and this is really deeply ingrained,
not just doing the kind of public consciousness,
but within science as well.
Like,
um,
it's taken scientists a long time to figure actually even the fish,
I've got reasonably small brains to their body size.
That doesn't rule out them actually having signs of,
of what we might consider it to be higher intelligence and the ability to solve
problems,
to memorize things and,
and uh,
and do stuff that maybe at first we wouldn't expect.
So I've got a couple of examples of fish that I think helped to bust this myth
myth about them being kind of small minded,
kind of dumb creatures.
Um,
one of them is this guy,
the frill fin Gobi.
These guys live in the Gulf of Mexico on the,
um,
on the rocky shore.
They hot then habits,
um,
kind of shallow into tidal pools.
And what these guys do is when the tide is high,
they will swim around there.
Any little fish probably about Yay big.
They'll swim around and look at the environment around them and basically
memorize the shape of the seabed and they're working out.
But when the sea level drops,
when the tide goes out,
they'll know where the pockets of water will remain,
where the pools are going to form a,
and this could save their life.
And I'm going to explain this with some,
some really high tech illustrations that I did,
unfortunately didn't get a tech to do these ones.
Um,
so no expense has been set at all with this illustration I made of the leaping
gobies.
So,
um,
here we go.
So the c level is coming down.
We've got our goby in the blue fish here and our Predator is this lovely
activists.
Um,
the times coming down and what he doesn't want to do is end up in a pool,
uh,
stuck a predator.
So what does he do?
So he can jump to safety,
but he needs to know which way to jump isn't want to jump out on land.
That would be pretty bad for him.
But basically they have,
because they've memorized the shape of their environment,
they know exactly the right direction and the distance to jump and they will do
that,
um,
when they need to and they will get away to safety.
Um,
which is pretty cool.
And even more cool is the fact that,
um,
the scientists who studied this then thought,
well,
we'll take them away for a bit and see what happens.
So they've collected these fish up,
kept them in a kind of blank aquarium tank for a couple of weeks,
I think maybe up to a month,
putting them back into their natural environments.
And low and behold they still remember what to do.
And as soon as they get stuck in the wrong pool where the Predator,
they know where to go and how to jump to get this kind of exit route,
uh,
to save their skin.
So,
you know,
these guys definitely are not just,
they're definitely have longer than the three second memory and they have this
spatial mapping,
their heads of,
of what's going on.
And,
and you can see how this has evolved too as if survival strategy so that they
don't end up getting big octopus food.
Now another of my favorite examples of a fish that really shows us,
it's got more smarts than you might imagine are the cleaner wrasse not,
these aren't particularly good pictures is in my focus.
Again,
I'm not a very good photographer yet,
but it's basically this stripey little thing,
a short guy in the front on the left hand side,
black and white.
And then this scan of the left,
the right hand side,
I was taking a picture of this big white fish with black stripes and didn't even
realize that behind,
um,
uh,
was another fish being clean.
So the cleaner ras you find on coral reefs and they play really important role
in the ecosystem because they pick off parasites and dead skin from other fish.
And in fact,
we've shown that if you take cleaner wrasse away from an area of coral reef,
uh,
the official basically get pretty sick,
you know,
they suffer from more diseases and they start getting pretty six.
They need this service to have all these nasty bits and pieces taken off of
them.
Um,
it doesn't just fish the get clean though.
I'm going to show you a little video of these guys are just kind of
program to clean
whatever comes along.
Um,
so you can have your teeth done if you want.
Hopefully they're not finding any parasites in them.
But I'm not sure about that.
So yes,
Russell just
they will just come in whenever they come across and that are after mainly are
these things couldn't have fired.
I supports the kind of like texts of the sea.
They latch onto fish,
suck their blood for a couple of hours and then drop off.
Fish would much rather have them picked off by a cleaner wrasse.
Um,
but the rest,
I mean,
they will eat thousands of these things a day.
They are constantly,
constantly feeding the fish,
coming to their cleaning stations,
hundreds of them each day.
Um,
and they are stuffing themselves with ice supports with these parasites and for
essentially what they would rather do if they can get away with it,
is not eat the ice pods,
but take a nice bite of skin,
maybe the flesh and the mucus on the outside of a,
especially in on coral reefs,
the slime that Fisher covered it in,
it's actually full of Sunscreen,
which helped stop them from getting sunburned.
It's a pretty important in this sunny environment.
Um,
they don't make that sunscreen themselves.
They have to get it in their food from bacteria and their food or you can lick
it off another fish.
Um,
but the cleaner Ras know that there's only certain times when they can get away
with cheating basically.
Cause a fish would rather not have to make,
you know,
he'll,
it'll bite that it's been,
it's got from this cleaner asset,
really just wants a good service if it's having as parasites removed.
Um,
but this is where we really start to see the smarts of these little fish coming
out.
And it's coming.
It's through scientists who've been studying these things for the last 10 years
or so,
and spending hours and hours and hours watching cleaner ass in the wild and also
in the board at trees.
And they've showing that these guys have got a really smart way of,
uh,
figuring out how they should behave.
And they will memorize all of the clients that come to their,
to this cleaning station and know exactly which ones,
which they will be able to distinguish between different species.
So simplistically,
one of the first things they will figure out as well as it a herbivore or a
predator.
Um,
if it's a fairly harmless herbivore like this surgeon fish on the lefthand side,
um,
then it can occasionally get away with a bit of cheating because there's not too
much harm done.
But,
uh,
if it is a Predator like this moray eel on the right hand side,
you better behave pretty good because,
um,
it's pretty extraordinary that this fish could climb into the mouth of a
Predator or not just get eaten.
There's this truth that has struck in a clean the cleaning station that only
happens in this very special place anywhere else on the reef.
And that more at your,
we'll just eat that Ras straight up.
But somehow they,
they maintain this,
this kind of agreement that that's not going to happen.
And it partly happens because the Ras behaves really well.
It doesn't cheat.
Um,
and it also knows that it can own basically kind of manipulate that,
uh,
other fish by giving it a massage essentially.
So they will,
um,
they will rub themselves,
their fins over the body of,
of the,
uh,
the bigger fish.
And studies have shown that the fish actually enjoy this so well they certainly,
their stress hormones drop and they seem to relax.
Um,
but you know,
you can interpret that as enjoyment if you like.
It's possible even that some of these fish come to get clean so often and
they'll come like many,
many times a day,
uh,
because it feels nice,
you know,
and they do seem to have this kind of,
they shiver and they stop and they will just sort of be in this trance as this
little fish flix over its body rubbing and massaging.
And that's also what the rattle do if they cheat.
So we kind of know that it is almost apologizing.
So,
so say it's cleaning a herbivore which isn't going to eat it and also it will
look and see who else is around.
So if there's a big long queue of other fish waiting,
they tend to be pretty well behaved because they don't want to because they know
that there's other fish could just swim off.
And go get clean someplace else.
And they rely on that.
They do rely on fish coming to be who to be clean for their food.
It's,
but if the queue is kind of short and not too many people,
what other fish waiting and if it's her before then,
yeah,
I'll try and cheat and take some,
take some slime.
But they will apologize and they will immediately kind of rob and smoothed over
the fish and sort of say he don't,
I'm sorry.
Don't swim off.
Please don't swim off.
And you know,
and usually it works and they kind of settle down and there a case.
So,
so yes.
So the clean air act and there's lots of other aspects of their lives that
really surprising.
Um,
they often operate in pairs.
So a men and a female will were clean together.
Uh,
and the male has the female totally kind of controlled because,
um,
she must never cheat because if she cheats and eats too much mucus and grows too
big,
she could change sex,
turn into a male and steal his territory.
Um,
cause he's the one of the sex changing species of fish that we have.
and he really doesn't want his partner to end up and kind of grabbing his
territory.
So if he sees her cheating,
he is mean to her.
And we'll basically kind of chase her and bite her because he knows this,
it's really bad.
So the female has to sort of,
if she's with him,
she has to behave.
So there's loads of crazy things going on in their lives.
And so basically the cleaner Ras is showing us that despite their small size and
a small brains,
they have evolved and the need to have quite complex social lives to be able to
communicate,
uh,
to understand the,
that there's different types of fish and to,
to change and tailor their services according to what's going on around them.
And those are all things that maybe we wouldn't have expected not so long ago
that fish could leave such,
such kind of nuanced lives and not just,
it's not just a hardwired behavior.
This is responding and solving problems and,
and really kind of smart ways so that there's the keener us.
Okay.
I'm going to move on to,
um,
another myth that we get in the fish world and I'm going to come back to my
favorites.
Uh,
lady Marie Fish.
Um,
so another idea that has kind of been around for a long time is that fish are
silent and that they don't make any sounds.
Um,
I remember as a kid,
uh,
reading books and if there were lots of animals and the books I could do,
I could do the noises,
I can do the cows and the sheep and the darks.
But whenever there was a fish in the picture,
I was kind of stumped,
you know,
what noise does the fish make?
It's pretty tricky.
Um,
and,
and we kind of assume that they don't make any sense,
but they,
they actually do.
And this lady got involved in understanding more about the sounds of fish and it
was after the Second World War and the US Navy,
we're actually the ones who were interested in knowing about fish sounds.
Uh,
because,
uh,
the war effort had been conducted quite a lot of it had been conducted
underwater.
There were submarines for the first time.
Hydrophones had been invented to listen for enemy Warcraft.
Only half the time all they could hear was just sounds of animals underwater and
it was really getting in the way.
So,
um,
for the next 20 years after the Second World War,
marine fish at the University of Rhode Island was funded by the u s navy to
basically go out and record the voices of fish to figure out when are they
noisy,
what species make these sounds,
where are they just try and kind of listened through this cacophony of sounds
they were making.
So,
and that's what she did.
Um,
she was apparently given a Chevrolet Wagoner's her kind of fish listening
station.
She would drive around the coast of Maine and New England and this was packed
out with the equipment,
the latest hydrophones miles of cables,
walkie talkies,
all sorts of really cool stuff.
I don't have a picture of what that looked like,
but I kind of imagined it looked a bit like this.
I'm only,
she wasn't looking for to bust the ghosts.
She was trying to find fish to record their voices and she did.
She recorded hundreds of different fish voices.
And I'm just going to play a couple of years for you now cause these are
available on archives online.
Um,
just to give you an idea of these are the sorts of thousand fish,
make 'em no prizes for guessing help.
This one got its name.
This is the grunt.
Quite loud.
Sorry.
Yep.
So there we go.
A grunting fish.
Um,
there was this guy again,
no prizes for guessing the new name.
Oh,
it's nice.
Hang on a second.
Segments good or become that.
That's an amazing sound.
That's a male Croker talking to a female and I can see,
I can see him
how they respond to that.
You've got to see Robin as well.
Kind of sounds like it's balling thing.
Amazing sounds.
Okay.
So first make loads of sounds and there's hundreds of fish that she recorded and
analyzed their different sounds like we're making.
And um,
and we now know that fish makes sounds for all sorts of different reasons.
This is a Damsel,
fish and other fish from a coral reef.
They are very angry,
a territorial fish.
And if you come close today,
they farm seaweed on the reef and if you come close to that little territory,
they will try and scare you off,
even if you're a human scuba diver and they will chat to their teeth together
and make this drumming sound and you can hear it in the water and I'll swim at
you and try and scare you off.
Um,
uh,
other fish will make sounds,
to,
to court each other to make,
uh,
to sort of attract,
partners,
um,
during fights.
So Piranhas,
how about these three different calls?
We think that,
uh,
that they use at different points of their fights when it's the beginning of a
fight and they're just kind of checking each other out in the middle of a fight,
there'll be a different sound.
And then the victor has a kind of victory,
a kind of chant that it shouts out and says like,
I win,
you lose to come back.
Um,
they make the sounds and various different ways.
So,
uh,
the grunt is grinding.
It's second set of teeth together.
A lot of fish.
I have a second,
a set of teeth at the back of their throats called the pharyngeal teeth.
He's a three d printed version of these guys,
I think a brilliant use of three d printing and they grind their teeth together
to make those kind of grunting sounds.
The other thing fish do is user an organ in their body called the swim bladder,
which we actually think of old from lungs.
That fish did evolve lungs quite early on and then secondarily evolved this
organ which they use primarily as a flotation device,
does sorting from sinking under water but also to make sounds.
So,
um,
they do this and lots and lots of different ways.
I'm going to show you one more video clip of a noisy fishes,
a toad fish making some sounds.
She's pretty dramatic
and well that fish is doing is uh,
it has a muscle on the outside of it's from [inaudible] and it's by bracing that
balloon,
uh,
to make their sounds trigger fish,
which we showed in that video earlier.
They will drum their fins against this from Datto.
So kind of use it as a drum skin,
which is,
which is pretty cool.
And then I always have to give this example,
especially when I'm talking to kids.
So,
uh,
there's just the herring which allow let little bubbles of gas out of their swim
bladders,
they fill us from Bella's up from their mouths,
the steroid connection through to that,
uh,
from the air.
But they let out these bubbles at night time to kind of coordinate their
shoulders so they know what they are and the shoal and it's dark and they let
small bubbles out,
which will make a little sound,
but it comes out of their bums.
And the scientists who discovered this called it the fast repetitive tick.
And I'm not kidding his,
the science paper that it came from,
uh,
what's quite fun.
So fish,
it makes sense for all sorts of reasons.
They are much more sonic than we ever thought they were.
And we're still understanding how this kind of fits into their ecology and how
they're using sound.
Um,
uh,
to,
to yeah,
to as a,
as an important resource that they have available to,
to communicate with each other.
Okay.
So we've had sound,
we've had a fish smarts and brains,
uh,
which are things that we sort of don't necessarily think much of in the fish
world.
The book also,
um,
I try to address and look at some of the aspects of fish lives that are unique
to the fish and the things that they do that you really don't see in other
groups of animals,
certainly in other groups of vertebrates.
And there are some things that fish just really,
really good at and have extraordinary abilities that nothing else really has.
And one of those things is bioluminescence the ability to make light.
Um,
there are 1500 species of fish that have,
that we know of at the moment that have this ability to make light.
Um,
and this things like the flashlight fish here,
which has,
um,
uh,
basically has like headlights on the front of it to see through the dark.
Um,
there's the angler fish.
If any of you seen that lolly documentary finding Nemo,
I think you should be familiar with Angler fish and the fact that they have
this,
um,
this layer at the front of their heads which dangles down and then it tracks
food into their big mouth.
This picture actually comes from just recently taken from a piece of footage off
the coast of the Azores in the middle of the Pacific islands down of about 800
meters.
And I believe it's one of the first pieces of footage showing live.
Um,
female angler fish,
which are the big ones that you can see,
but with a male trailing along behind her.
And I should think you can just make out here,
there's a spike in them sticking down from her is the degenerative tiny male who
basically is a parasite and kind of grabs onto her and his skin will fuse with
hers and he'll just drag around with her and then he,
she will use him when,
when she needs to.
Uh,
so,
so that's pretty cool.
So that's the first time we've seen that.
And also,
I think hopefully you can just make out,
they've got this kind of net of feelers,
like tentacles coming out,
um,
which may also be bioluminescent the kind of hard to see in the picture.
Um,
it's,
we're not sure,
but they seem to have maybe,
maybe they work a bit like cat's whiskers.
They're sensing things in the,
in the water around them.
Um,
so yeah,
so fish are very bioluminescent.
Here's a diagram of the fish family tree and,
um,
1500 species,
but they're dotted all through the evolutionary tree.
We think maybe on 30 separate occasions,
fish have evolved to glow in the dark.
This is something that just keeps happening.
Um,
and it's an example I think of showing that fish,
these 30,000 species are really this wonderful experiments and evolution and in
life.
And we can see,
you can understand more about bigger questions of evolution and the natural
world through the fish,
um,
and things like this.
So it's the fact that it's,
um,
it's so common to evolve.
Bioluminescence and fishes is not a big difficult question to answer.
It's really dark down there.
We're talking about fish that live mostly down in what we call the midnight
zone,
beyond a thousand meters down,
3000 feet.
We're no sunlight riches.
Um,
so it makes sense that if there's no light around,
then making your own light is super useful for seeing through the dark
protracting food for attracting mates and all those kinds of things.
So you know,
this is something the fish have returned to again and again.
Um,
they aren't all in the midnight zone,
I should say.
There are some that live a little bit higher up in what we call the twilight
zone.
So this is between about 200 meters,
so 600 feet down into the midnight zone.
And this is where we get just mostly really dark blue light.
All the other wavelengths of light had been absorbed by water,
um,
leaving the short wave length,
blue light.
Uhm,
especially why the oceans are blue because that's the light that penetrates the
deepest.
And one of the creatures that live down there is the sky,
the velvet belly lantern shark,
a fully going shop that you could hold in the palm of your hand,
which is pretty cool and it has blue bioluminescence all across its belly.
And the reason it does that is so that it can hide in this area,
the twilight zone.
Because imagine if you're down there basically looking up towards the surface,
you would see this deep,
beautiful,
deep blue light.
I'm similar to if you stepped out at twilight out on land and you'd look up and
you see this dark blue sky,
and then if a a bat or a bird flew overhead,
you'd see it's dark silhouette,
and if you were a predator,
you'd think a,
Ha,
there's my food.
Same thing happens in the deep ocean,
in the twilight zone.
If a bunch of fish swim by and the Predator sees those shadows,
they know where to aim for.
But of course bio luminescence helps to get around that and it helps these fish
to hide in plain sight.
Now lots of fish do this.
They have maybe lines of bioluminescence down their bellies to kind of break up
their silhouettes.
They don't look so much like fish.
We get something like the velvet very lantern shark,
which just match entire the whole co,
um,
the cover their entire bellies with blue lights that matches the light around
them and they can adjust the intensity of that like depending on where they are
in the water column.
So it's like a cloak of invisibility,
which is really quite awesome.
Um,
just a quick one,
if you're interested to know how bioluminescence actually works.
Um,
uh,
half of the fish basically have chemicals that they have genes that produce
chemicals in their bodies that produced that's light.
Um,
we generically call one of the molecules Lucifer suffering.
It's actually a whole bunch of different things.
It can be,
but that's,
that's the name it's come up with.
And an enzyme called luciferase.
Again,
it could be different things,
but basically it's an oxygenation reaction.
It speeds up a Salissa phrase.
It speeds up the reaction in the Lucifer,
even with oxygen.
And the outcome is a,
is photons of light.
So about half the fish have these deans and that's what happens.
And half of them have bacteria that are bioluminescent and they have organs in
their body where they kind of nurture those bacteria and,
and make like that way.
Um,
and this I think has to be the most ingenious,
um,
example of a bioluminescent fish that illuminated net devil,
uh,
because it does both.
It has both in its lurid sticking up from its head.
She has bacteria and that's kind of a bulb at the end and she's got this
beautiful beard down at the bottom,
um,
which is a chemical reaction.
So she's evolved bioluminescence twice within the same fish,
which is just extraordinary and wonderful.
Um,
so there we go.
So bioluminescence doesn't happen in any other vertebrates.
Um,
fish are the only ones that do it and my goodness,
they do it.
And it's just one example I think of some of the stuff that fish do that's quite
surprising.
Um,
but it suits them perfectly to this,
this extraordinary world.
They live in this deep,
dark ocean,
deep blue ocean that's so different from us and the world that we know out on
land.
So that's about all I'm going to talk about.
And it gives me,
brings me to a brilliant points where I can hand over to Aaj,
uh,
cause I want to introduce you to some of the beautiful artwork that he's done.
So not only have we got the front cover,
but for each chapter,
Ada has produced us full page illustration to go with the subject matter of the
chapter.
And,
um,
from my perspective,
the process of how this happens and how this artwork came to be was,
was quite a simple one.
I would write my chapter,
um,
I would decide what the chapter was about.
I would gather ideas of the key characters in that chapter.
So this is the chapter about bio luminescence and the sorts of awesome deep sea
fish.
Um,
and then I would send a list of fish names,
Brian,
an email from Cambridge in Britain and ping them over the ocean,
uh,
to California.
And then some time later,
some beautiful artwork appears in my inbox.
And that's about all I know about the whole price.
So I would love to hand over to Aja to maybe tell us a bit more about the
process from your point of view.
Cause I said Madison it's a little bit more involved than the magic box that you
seem to be from my point of view a little bit more.
Where's your clicker?
Oh sorry,
I left it inside there.
Okay.
So this is one I think both of our,
one of our favorite drawings in the book.
Um,
I love deep sea fish so I tore into this one with a lot of enthusiasm.
but yeah,
the process for this would basically be held on with,
send me an email with a list of species this and you know,
I think I'd like to have all of these in the drawing and then I've got to come
up with a way to make that look,
you know,
natural but kind of not so natural.
Cause obviously this isn't necessarily what the deep sea ocean looks like.
Um,
this is kind of a party going on.
and I think in this particular one it was pretty challenging because you want it
to show the boat,
the ties in with the researcher,
the original researcher who discovered a lot of these species and I think late
18 hundreds or you okay.
Yeah.
So I had to draw,
you know,
my little version of a period boat from that time.
Um,
and then you,
you had the idea of one in a rope to come down and said,
we're kind of looking up,
we're seeing the boat,
we're seeing the rope and all these different species and that's quite something
to wrap my head around as a designer and illustrator.
Um,
plus you had,
you had your mile long list.
I even added some to this.
Um,
but so usually what I do is I start out with just some really basic kind of
rough thumbs like this and I started feeling it out.
Um,
actually this is where I start.
So really simple,
just sketching in real quick.
But with this drawing I pretty much had it from the very get go.
The idea like how this could go down is in my head,
refined it a bit here.
Um,
I think I moved the Lantern Shark over and kind of puzzled,
you know,
the sharks in there.
Um,
and then I would send,
so I wouldn't show him that because any illustrator will tell you,
never show him your thumbnails because the editors and the,
and the authors,
anyone else,
we started freaking out like,
oh boy,
you know,
I dunno dude,
if you were cut out for the job,
um,
and every pro illustrator will draw that sloppy in the first stages.
Um,
so you don't want to show that,
but this,
this,
you know,
tightened up a bit.
Uh,
so this is the rough I would send over and everybody would,
you know,
you'd,
you'd have your critiques and whatnot.
Um,
I managed to get the boat in there and showed the rope and the kind of illusion
of maybe we're looking at a trail of animals going up to the,
to the boat,
um,
even through some mountains in there to show the kind of,
cause a lot of this was done pretty far up north.
Right.
And the research,
oh,
it's like this global journey.
But I do love the fact you have the mountains and cause I think there's a lot of
classic images of the time of like,
yeah,
here's the boat and the sort of scenery.
Like they would never have seen it live face.
But I feel like that topic,
I think I must've been channeling,
I don't know if he knew if you've watched the show,
the terror,
but I had ride read that book and a want to go,
but it's basically a British expedition.
We'd go up to the Arctic,
you know?
And so I was thinking it was that same time period.
So I'm like,
Oh,
well you've got to have the Arctic and there's this some kind of mountains.
But anyways,
um,
everything he or she wanted except for this one,
this is a Ninja Lantern Shark.
Let's see if it gets to the real thing.
And that's a really cool species.
Maybe you guys have heard of it.
It was actually,
it was all over the Internet last year.
Um,
my friend Vicky Vasquez,
who's a local shark researcher,
discovered it and her young nephew,
I believe helped her name it,
hence the Ninja Lantern Shark.
It's an all black shark and it's bioluminescent all the way down.
Um,
something like God,
we got include that.
That's super cool.
And then we got a cookie cutter,
which is the super weird scary shark.
They will latch on to Wales and kind of twist and carve out a perfect,
like a cookie cutter chunk of flesh.
Um,
whales,
dolphins,
even other sharks there.
They're pretty nasty,
but only about this big,
but they had teeth.
It's like something out of a horror movie.
Really wild.
Um,
fight for fish,
dragon fish.
This is called loose jaw cause this whole bottom job just completely comes out
and you can see right through it.
And it's just like an appendage blind with super little needle teeth.
Um,
this is one of my favorite and strangest fish and he was kind of making the
rounds on the Internet,
I'd say about three or four years ago.
That was Monterey Bay.
Yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
Actually,
I think it was Ambari we're going to go talk to next week.
I'm the Monterey Bay Aquarium Research Institution Institute.
This fish has developed the ability,
so these two little slits here are it's actual eyelids to develop,
the ability to pop its eyes back out from his eyelids and look straight up
through it's translucent skull.
That way you can see prey and or predators coming at it from above.
So this whole top dome is just clear.
So it's like the creepiest thing ever.
Um,
and I got to kind of figure out how to draw that in a black and white ink
drawing.
But yeah,
so this was one of our favorites.
Um,
composition lean,
you know,
as an artist you,
you try to just fit everything in with,
with the fluid motion.
I like to add some natural interact,
you know,
interactive elements.
This guy's obviously chasing these guys.
This dude is just trying to be part of the party,
which like personality wise,
I also try to kind of capture their personality.
So,
um,
so the Angler fish is just like here,
it goes over given me and then the,
you know,
the sharks are kind of the rock stars.
They're up top.
Um,
I forget the species name of this little dude,
not the lantern,
but it's the most prolific,
like one of those prolific.
Yeah,
I think so.
I can find out.
I'll quiz you on that.
Um,
oops,
that's you.
So that was a lot of fun.
Um,
and then one of the ways that we have found each other is I own a tee shirt
company called cotton crustacean,
which originally I started with the focus on prehistoric marine animals.
Um,
long story super short,
did a Kickstarter to launch the thing.
One of the rewards was if you pay x amount of money,
you get to pick the animal as long as it's aquatic or prehistoric.
That way I could maybe get some cold dinosaurs in there.
If somebody picked it,
I would draw that animal,
I would include in the tee shirt line and you'd get the original art.
Um,
this one guy went down to an aquarium with his son.
He was a fan of what I was doing before.
So he knew of me,
really wants to support and we've done an aquarium with his son to go see the
Argonaute octopus that was washing up kinda down,
not the long beach aquarium,
but there's another little aquarium down there,
I think it's called the [inaudible] aquarium.
Um,
and so he went down there and he did the Kickstarter reward.
And you know,
again,
like when I came up with that idea,
I was hoping people to be like,
yeah,
Mazda,
soar and Chronos source and I'll really cool big,
you know,
TV toothy things.
And he says,
well I want an organized,
which is about at,
at the largest,
maybe this big.
Usually they're really small.
They're also called paper.
Nautilus is,
um,
cause what it is,
it's the only octopus that makes a shell alive today.
The female does it excretes it from the palms of your hands and it's like super
paper thin.
It was like an eggshell,
that's all.
Like,
oh,
all right.
So I got to do that and ended up doing the drawing.
It's become my most popular shirt.
I cannot keep them in stock.
And if you Google the Argonaute octopus,
it is like the third or fourth image in the top row,
even with just other,
you know,
photographs and whatnot.
Um,
it's definitely the first illustration you'll find online.
And so when she was writing spirals and time,
which she talks about the Oregon at octopus in,
she was,
I think you were googling literally,
uh,
images are going out.
Octopuses came across my drawing,
track me down through whatever websites hit me up.
And here we are now on our second book.
Um,
but originally my whole focus was giant monsters,
fish like this.
And so when she said,
I have a chapter with all these guys in there,
I was stoked.
And then she sent me the list of species.
It was this long.
So again,
I have to sit there and think,
well,
how do we add all these guys in there and make it kind of fun and not have it
just so overwhelming.
Um,
and the other main thing here with prehistoric animals,
which is usually the case when people talk about dinosaurs,
they show like TRX and stegosaurs hanging out.
But those two animals are 70 million years apart.
They never knew each other.
The same with the prehistoric fish and you know,
invert and whatnot,
250,
almost 300 million years of these guys before dinosaurs.
So when we're talking about species like a peer,
this is the both real epis,
that bony guy way up there,
the Gogo fish,
this little guy found on the Google reef in Australia.
Um,
they're from the Devonian era,
so we're talking 350 ish,
almost 400,
400 million years ago around there.
Um,
part of a family of fish that are long gone,
but they were called plaque of derms and they were usually armored and the first
half,
like a little tank and then their soft bodies would be out,
you know,
behind them.
These dudes were all any range,
maybe at the biggest about this big fresh and salt water would eat scum and
stuff on the bottom,
but they had the rock star because in which is the Dunkleosteus,
which is now becoming more and more popular and you know,
movies and books and video games and whatnot.
Basically the size of a school bus with a head,
like a snapping turtle.
So we had to have them in there.
I think you had the idea of them fighting.
So I got this guy doing the cheap shot and biting him.
I like to say that is because we found evidence that they did fight.
I think that's like fossils with like clearly like injuries that could only have
been inflicted by another done class.
Right.
So like
a good og,
I could kind of listen for doing that.
Imagine the skulls.
We find it,
these guys are about this wide and there's not even necessarily teeth.
It's like,
uh,
they're,
they're armored kind of bone.
Exos skull formed into the wedges of,
you know,
the,
the plates I can like a turtle would be almost like a bird beak.
Um,
you know,
God knows how heavy about the size of a bus.
So I saw a lot of shirts with these guys on as you can imagine,
kids love this kind of stuff.
But then on your list you had something,
I can't even really pronounce it the moment we were trying to figure how to say
it last night,
I could have a Carpool foma got her.
I think I got a second.
A little tip.
I also make sure the back of the book,
there's this,
uh,
there's a key so we know what they were though cause this is very potent to me.
It is a Harpo.
Hang on.
Whoa paygo to Tor.
Yes.
How Pega for two times,
that little dude with the,
yeah.
And so of course I'd never heard of that and I go online to look it up and
there's like maybe three sketches of one drawn.
Um,
and like the worst fossil print you can,
you know,
you would never be able to tell that it looked like this.
And so as a scientific illustrator,
when you,
when you come across that you kind of have to base your stuff both off of
whatever published drawings or are out there and findings.
Um,
I think one or even two of those three drawings weren't even professional.
So there was like one true professional scientific illustration of it.
So I knew the layout,
the fins,
he's just these little tiny dudes.
Um,
and obviously when you draw it that small,
I'm not going to get that detailed anyways.
He ends up kind of looking like little marsh and guy.
I'm amazed that you didn't just say no,
no,
I think I'll do that.
But it's cool.
Disliked his name so much.
I want to include them,
but then these guys are all kind of rock star prehistoric sharks.
This is the step that campus and while he,
while he's known as,
cause he has his kind of radar dish,
weird dorsal fin that has spikes on it.
Um,
pretty small,
sharp,
but the size is like a grey reef shark.
Um,
this is the Dustin gigantic.
Yes.
And he's from the carboniferous period.
So when the planet was kind of overrun with insects,
super lush forests,
um,
pretty much nothing else really cruising around.
It was like the,
the time of the insects,
the ocean.
We had these dudes and they had a single row of teeth and their upper and lower
jaw,
it would come down like scissors.
And they were bigger than an average,
modern,
great white shark,
about 25 feet long.
So,
you know,
almost the length of,
not the length of this room going this way.
So He's super cool.
But all we have in the fossil record of these guys are here just,
just the actual job moons.
So with sharks,
because they're not an actual skeletal fish,
they're on a bony fish,
skeletons made of cartilage,
doesn't fossilize hardly at all.
And so we have to kind of guesstimate,
you know,
and base them off of more prehistoric sharks are live today that we know have
been around because we've found their teeth and we're not in the fossil record.
So in the bay we have seven gill sharks to super prehistoric shark because we've
found fossils of the exact teeth from 200 million years ago.
Um,
and then this dude who doesn't necessarily get the limelight,
like his other buddies here has become one of the biggest rock stars called the
helicoprian.
And his bottom jaw was basically like,
well,
this is what we would find to tooth world.
It's just a row,
a single row of teeth,
like a saw blade.
And for a hundred plus years if theologists and paleontologists,
we tried to figure out where that tooth world would go.
And so there's all these amazing ancient if theology drawings of that tooth
world on his head,
on his butt,
on his tail as a dorsal fin,
like side Sob fins,
you know,
sideways,
all sorts of crazy stuff.
And it's really only,
um,
much to my disappointment when I started my tee shirt company in the last five
years,
we've,
we've Kinda got it nailed down that it's stuck in the lower jaw.
It would actually have molars and the top and the saw would come up and there's
just enough kind of cheek bones left in,
I forget what museum had it,
but they did a 3-d Lino recreation of it and it all fit together like a puzzle
piece.
The reason why I say as my disappointment is cause when I started a
conversation,
I drew the healer cooperating with the old school way,
which is almost like the bottom job was like a whip that came around and twirled
around like that.
And it's so,
it's such a common way to depict that,
that it's like in Jurassic Park video games and,
and other stuff.
So I start my teacher comfy,
do the Kickstarter,
I make 120 helicoprian shirts with the kind of whip jaw.
Three months later the latest findings come out and they're like,
hey,
by the way,
it's a buzz saw in the job and it's not even this like giant monsters,
great white look and thing.
It's the kind of a giant rat fish,
which is a relative of the sharks.
It's cartilage dentist.
They're also called ghost sharks.
Um,
kind of like a Dumbo looking elephant of have a little mini shark,
but I like the drum still a little more panache.
Um,
this is the lead seek theories from saying that,
right.
Like the biggest bony fish ever,
um,
bigger than a school bus sent me just 45,
I think maybe 50 feet around there.
Um,
filter feeder,
just super slow,
would cruise around in packs.
Um,
and he was more around in the Mesozoic.
So if I'm remembering right,
uh,
late Triassic maybe around there.
Yeah.
Luckily there's no paleontologists in the crowd.
Like,
well,
yeah.
So,
um,
and the,
you know,
the same,
same deal.
Here's how I figured all that out.
Just working out the different things,
figuring out who I wanted to have the focus on.
Um,
this is the first sketch here.
I was trying to have the big Ol Dunkleosteus in there,
but it got a little crowded,
got more of a figure ass.
And with any composition when I'm trying to do is I'm also trying to guide the
eye through the piece.
Um,
so with these roughs,
you know,
I had pretty much nailed that and figure that out.
Um,
but yeah,
so there's that and I'll show you one more.
This was also a favorite of ours.
Um,
so there's the final of this one.
What's the name of this chapter
from the deep?
So Helen gave me a list of fish,
again,
a mile long,
most of them fresh water,
but from all over the world.
And then one salt water being an aquarium guy,
having owned a fish store and whatnot.
We get really particular about mixing fish from different parts of the world
because if you're doing that,
you're just doing it just to have a fancy looking fish tank.
You're not actually trying to create a bio tope and accurate and your
representation.
So we have Amazon tanks,
we have a Asian river tanks,
we have African Riffe Lake sichlid tanks.
Um,
so she gave me this list of all these different species.
And first it's like,
oh,
we can't do that.
He just,
uh,
you kidding me.
But I gave in.
And so,
um,
originally this was a had fish,
believe it or not,
this thing is not a branch that is a pretty disgusting fish called the Hagfish,
which is slimy and kind of brainless and you know,
maybe a deserves that reputation that you're trying to break with fish.
Um,
there was an image going around on the Internet,
I believe.
Was it this guy where the car was carrying like a,
a slew of these in a big Ben and it's back and then I think the car got in an
accident or the thing tipped over.
And what these guys do is they secrete this totally nasty slime kind of
substance and you can take one and put it in a bucket and it would fill the
bucket with that.
Simon could generate that much kind of the Sliwa like ectoplasm looking,
you know,
Ghostbusters,
um,
kind of,
you know,
substance.
Anyways,
so those,
his car,
it's carrying a whole giant like plastic band probably had like 300 of them.
And the slime completely just took over the car.
It exploded all over is all over the street.
It was all over the cars.
It had looked like something out of Ghostbusters.
Like there's something that just came in and slammed it.
Um,
problem is,
you know,
I liked having him in there.
He's a saltwater and that's all mixed fish from different parts of the Robo and
won't mix the salt water fish with the fresh water fish because my reputation's
on the line here.
So hagfish got taken out.
Um,
but what we have is some really big super strange freshwater fish.
have you been to cal academy and Golden Gate Park?
There's a big tank full of the alligator Gar.
It's one of my favorite and they get ginormous 10,
12 feet.
Um,
you would find them in actually rather shallow rivers and whatnot and like say
Texas,
um,
we'll find them the Mississippi.
But they're definitely the really common in Texas,
a super slow moving.
They're becoming almost endangered because obviously in Texas this,
this would be a thing.
People like to go hunting with bows and arrows.
So these big guys come up,
you know,
without a care in the world up to the surface.
And dudes come out on boats and yeah,
they pluck them.
So it's,
it's,
yeah,
and it actually has a rope on the arrows of their fishing with the actual arrow.
Um,
so populations are being depleted pretty quick,
which is a tragedy.
Um,
but they're not quite on the endangered list yet,
I don't think.
But I love those guys.
You can see him at the California Academy of Sciences.
Um,
big white sturgeon.
We would get these right here in the bay.
Um,
I grew up in Sacramento.
You would,
you would get these in the delta and Sacramento River.
Um,
they're Nadia missed,
right?
It's the right word to say.
Then a freshwater and salt.
It can kind of go back and forth.
Um,
also would get huge for a long time in Lake Tahoe,
there was rumor of a,
you know,
Taco zone,
sea monster.
They called it a Tessie,
I believe.
And then,
you know,
eventually somebody caught like a 15 foot one of these.
It was just an absolute monster
caviar,
you know,
I guess they're probably pretty good eating there.
They're definitely,
there's a fishery forum,
um,
a good place to see these.
If you go to aquarium in the bay down by pier 39,
which I know is like a pier 39,
but there is a legitimate little aquarium there call aquarium of the bay where I
used to work as a scuba diver and we have a huge population of these and the big
tunnel tanks and they're pretty impressive.
They're like very prehistoric animal right around since the dinosaurs.
Um,
and then these guys,
the paddle fish you'd find like in Missouri based in the northern states,
out in the rivers and lakes,
there's a couple of different quarries that have been populated with and the
divers will go just to see them.
Um,
it's a very strange,
fairly large fish,
um,
kind of built like a shark in a way even though it is totally a freshwater,
bony fish.
Um,
and then it has this really large weird paddle knows that comes out.
They I do think are on the endangered list.
Um,
yeah,
which sucks.
Their habitats are getting wiped out by pollution and damming of the rivers and
whatnot.
Um,
and then we have these guys,
the snakehead,
which you may have heard of because they are super invasive and are getting into
lakes and rivers everywhere and they eat everything.
And there,
Yay big.
If you've watched river monsters,
there's a great episode where that guy goes in and tries to find him a,
he gets bit by one and they're hyper aggressive.
Um,
and they were just kind of taken over,
uh,
don't know why they were introduced or how they got into,
especially up here in North America.
Um,
this is,
we were laughing at this fish cause I call it a biker and Bashir.
Yeah.
Um,
in the,
at least in the California aquarium trade,
we call them bikers.
Um,
and,
uh,
it's an African fish.
Right.
And my cool story about that is when you'd go,
so when I had my fish store,
I'd go to these tropical fish wholesalers,
which are big damn kind of dank warehouses,
but just rows and rows and rows of aquariums.
And that's where the fish doors would go to buyer fish and take it back to the
fish store.
And some of you guys,
um,
a lot of these places have drainage canals that the tanks could just easily be
overflow.
Nobody would,
would worry about water damage or anything.
Concrete floors,
drainage canals where the openings in them.
And what,
what happened a lot is these guys would get out of the tanks,
get into the drainage canals,
not go wash,
get washed out.
They would hang around,
eat whatever else comes down there and get really big.
And so sometimes you'd be at the wholesaler picking up your fish and you'd see
something go down these,
these pipelines,
you know,
with the open where it was open and it was these bikers that are just like
loving life living in this Super Mario tube world.
Um,
so they're cool.
Yeah,
very popular aquarium fish.
And then this guy is the land prey,
which is probably one of the most disgusting parasites,
parasites,
also fresh and salt water back and forth.
Uh,
you'd find them in the American river and the Delta,
um,
other freshwater rivers obviously.
Um,
but also out in the ocean.
And they liked the latch on with this crazy circular mouth.
It's just lined with teeth and kind of like the cookie cutter shark suck a chunk
out or at least just kind of draw blood and protein from the animal until they
could shake them.
Uh,
when salmon are coming up,
the stream to breed lamper is a jumping on those guys and hitching a ride.
Um,
and then last but not least,
these guys are so,
you know,
Texas,
Sacramento,
Missouri,
Africa,
everywhere,
everywhere.
And then she wanted African cyclics,
which are little super colorful fish that live in the rift,
um,
lakes of Africa and also their stick lives in the western rivers of Africa.
But,
um,
there are certain lakes like Lake Malawi where the water's pretty clear and
there are millions and millions of these almost tropical color like saltwater
fish,
um,
little guys called African secludes,
all sorts of from color types,
stripes and spots,
super neon blues and reds and Greens.
Someone was beautiful,
fresh water fish in the world.
I'm just swimming around in the rocky reefs.
Um,
it would make for amazing scuba diving,
but there's also hippos and crocodiles and God knows what else.
So,
um,
African Tiger fish,
I mean all sorts of things that would just ruin your day.
But as a kid,
the reason why these are my favorite and very popular aquarium fish,
if you get into keeping fresh water tanks,
often you would kind of cut your teeth on these guys on because they are so
colorful and they breed and whatnot.
So when I was a kid getting into aquariums,
it'd be like nine years old,
get on my BMX bike,
go down to the local fish store with like a jar of like dimes and nickels and I
would buy one of these fish,
bring it home.
They're hyper aggressive.
So I throw it,
not really knowing that yet,
learning about all this stuff,
throw it in my tank of Tetra is another kind of angel fish and watch it just
massacre everybody.
So I ended up with just one fish that would just dominate and then I go,
okay,
well I guess I'm going to keep African cichlids now it's like go get more.
And you know,
with every bag of chance I could scratch together.
Um,
but super cool,
completely out of place.
In this lineup of fish,
but for Helen,
I would do it.
Yeah.
So,
and that's kind of how we would come up with the drawings.
There's eight or nine other ones in there.
Um,
and the book,
she also tells really cool,
like folktales the fish from around the world.
And I would add a small kind of spirals,
Trish in each one.
And those are a lot of fun to read.
Um,
but yeah.
Cool.
And that's pretty much,
that's how it all comes about three,
it's late nights,
a lot of coffee and sitting there and you know,
hoping she likes it.
I do.
I really do.
Yeah,
so much.
Thank you so much.
That's awesome.
Yeah.
Cool.
Okay,
well I will say thank you to all of you for coming.
Thank you so much to Aja for being here and sharing insights that no one else
has had before.
I think that was exclusive,
well,
the odd of Ivus whole.
So,
um,
thank you.
Yeah.
Thank you so much for coming into enjoying off fish.
Wild.
Thanks.
Yeah.
Any questions?
Anyone in the room?
Q and a?
Anyone?
No worries.
No questions on the dory.
Yeah,
I'll read one of the questions from the door.
So we have online questions from the live stream.
I am interested to know how fishes pick their partners in the wild.
Are they generally monogamous?
And also what is your favorite fish?
Oh,
the favorite fish question.
I love,
do you?
Uh,
I've had it like four times now from kids and adults alike and it's really hard
to,
because there's 30,000 species to choose from.
Uh,
so I kind of have a daily favorite.
Um,
uh,
the moment I think my favorite is I think all the mandarin fish,
which is,
uh,
the only one of two animals in the world that have the blue pigment in them.
Uh,
every other blue was a structural color.
So Butterfly Wings,
it's the same reason that the sky is blue and that rainbows or blue,
it's the way they sort of physical interaction with the structure of the
material,
not a pigment.
And the only blue pigments I've been found in these beautiful fish,
which also,
uh,
um,
oh,
I think they are not monogamous,
but the males dance each night for the females.
And they have this wonderful kind of display.
Uh,
so the female will choose the male,
um,
based on his,
you know,
colors and dancing abilities.
So often it is the males in the fish that are having to show off to the females,
um,
and the females will choose.
And in fact,
there's a whole bunch of stuff in the chapter I write about color,
I'm talking about guppies and how they have evolved to be incredibly colorful,
but it's a real trade off between sex and danger.
And in their native habitats in Trinidad,
in the Caribbean,
they live in these little pools that have different levels of danger.
Some of them have loads of predators and some of them don't.
And in the pools with scientists basically realized that the pools with
predators had less colorful fish and then the ones that were safe and don't,
and then experiments show that it only takes about 18 months in captive
conditions and controlled conditions to change their colors.
So you take away the predators and the evil and the congeners patients become
more colorful because you don't want to be bright and sort of stand out if
there's things are going to eat you,
but you want to be colorful enough for a female to come and meet with you.
So this is sort of trade off between the two and some fish are monogamous,
aren't they?
I mean I'm seahorses,
I think parent for life and various others.
I think some of the sick,
let's do as well that can be quite quite good at staying in their partners,
sort of partnerships,
male females and some,
one of my favorites actually is a thing called the talk bass,
I believe.
And they're hermaphrodites um,
but they pair up for life and then about 20 times a day just flip between the
genders and that kind of swap over male,
female,
male,
female.
So it's pretty,
pretty cool.
So,
uh,
thanks for sharing insight into these animals.
A love than we would never get to see otherwise.
Uh,
but actually seeing them in person is really super cool.
And I'm assuming based on your photography that you've done some diving and I,
I think you mentioned that you're diving is,
is there like a favorite place you've dove or a like a dream location that you
would want to dive or someplace you'd recommend that people check out?
I don't sent me do,
I don't know if you do.
I do.
You go for it.
Um,
so yeah,
I do dive in.
It's really how I got into all of this in the first place.
I learned to drive and I was a teenager in England,
um,
which definitely wasn't clear and beautiful and full of lots of fish,
but it got me into it anyway.
And um,
but since then I've worked in,
researched and dived all around the world,
which has been a wonderful,
but actually when I was writing the book,
I had chance to go on a big long trip around the world.
I was actually first port call was here in California and Aja and I met a couple
of years ago for the first time,
which was great.
And then we carried on my husband and I carried on traveling around the world
and as much diving as we could and watching fish and kind of getting ideas for
this book.
And the final place we dived is a place I've wanted to go for two for a really
long time,
which is the island of Palau in the Pacific,
which is a sort of,
if you flew from here to Guam and then you carry on another one,
it's sort of out that way.
And I'd always heard about Palau is being like the divers scuba divers heaven.
It's now very strongly protected from over fishing that we've summit to be
beautiful.
And I had huge,
hugely high expectations for it and was kind of nervous that it would,
whether it would fulfill that.
There's also,
this was 2016 when there was a big heat wave that was coral bleaching going on
all over the world.
Plow had been hit by drought.
Um,
but,
uh,
it was fantastic.
It was absolutely blew me out of the water.
It just big old beautiful fish,
um,
that I hadn't seen for years.
Um,
or really ever in that kind of density of fish.
I studied for my phd,
which in the location I studied at in Malaysia and not being fished out and
they'd all gone,
but I saw them in Palau,
have these things called Hump headdress and huge numbers.
The risa beautiful and just extraordinary place for just like,
yeah,
sort of heaven,
not under,
under the sea really.
So yeah,
definitely go there,
right?
Yeah.
So I mentioned I dove with the aquarium,
Kramer the bay for a couple of years as a professional diver.
Then I dove at Cal Academy and go and get park and all this tanks.
I even dove at the rain forest cafe as a job for a short minute,
um,
which was pretty miserable,
but uh,
you know,
it paid the bills for a while.
Um,
and I got certified,
I was 16,
and growing up in Sacramento I was so obviously fish obsessed,
obsessed with the ocean that I would dive in the American river,
which ran through my suburban neighborhood of kind of Carmichael.
Um,
and you can imagine it was dreary and super cold and high current.
And I wouldn't be able to see you,
you know,
I a five or six feet visibility,
but we would get,
um,
we'd get striped bass of him from the ocean and we'd get shad.
And if I was super lucky,
had maybe see a surgeon,
but there a couple of times I,
I thought I saw like the big tail of one,
but I had startled as I came up on it,
you know,
which also started meetings anytime when you're dark,
murky water and something big comes at you,
there's always a moment.
Um,
so in some ways those kind of crummy dive spots where I'm like going through
like shopping carts and like I beams of the old bridge that I'm diving
underneath and all that kind of stuff are actually really nostalgic.
And you know,
kind of part of my favorite spots of all the spots I've dove from the
Philippines to Monterrey and Mexico,
like cozy metal stuff.
Um,
my all time favorite is Catalina island.
So an hour boat ride out of long beach and there's literally like an oceanic
paradise.
Um,
for me,
the best California diving,
it's warm enough that you don't feel like you're going to die after half an hour
of being underwater.
Um,
but because it's still temperate waters,
you know,
it's mid sixties,
you get a lot of the cool cold water species.
Um,
and you also get kelp force and live in the visibility there as much better than
Monterey,
which generally is on the best day,
10 or 15 feet.
Catalina it could be as much as 40 or 50.
Super blue and I cathedrals of giant Kelp coming up and over a giant Black Sea
bass decides the car's almost.
At least they,
they look like it when they come up on Ya.
Leopard Sharks Breeding and cruising around and the kelp,
occasionally a blue sharks and soup fin sharks,
smooth hound,
um,
giant balls of anchovies that are the size of a house.
They just block out the sun.
Um,
so that's my all time favorite spot,
but I haven't been as many spots that she has.
We'll see.
There you go.
Cool.
Yeah.
Thank you.
You're welcome.
Thank you very much.
Thank you very much for joining us.
I appreciate it.
Yeah,
they can't.
Cute.
Cool.
Yeah.